[Music]
hi guys my name is grace Helbig and do
not know now you know your life is
different now I used to do a lot of
videos where I give you guys advice on
things so I thought let's do it again
that's a little sample of what I sound
like in the bedroom and it's the time of
year where many of you are going back to
school so I went on my Facebook a while
ago and asked you guys for any questions
that you needed advice on in terms of
going back to school and let's get into
some gray spice many of you have a witty
interesting clever fun idea for a name
of whatever this segment could be leave
it in the comments down below
oh okay why do I can tie it at the same
time it was my impression of a college
student you tell your roommates you have
night terrors in that you scream you're
going to kill them and you receive or
just let them think you want to kill
them leave them wanting more information
about your medical history and exactly
psychologically what's happening with
you one of them might have a Taser
well people still think I'm cool if I
can't afford the nice binders and just
get cheap plastic ones or will that
destroy all the chances I have am making
friends people you have a computer which
is infinitely cooler than binders so how
do I get around the hole I have an open
pack of gum and other people have seen
and now wants them but I don't want to
share it but also I don't want to look
rude dilemma a Taser has to be openly
gay in the high school of a small rural
very Christian town some have sex with
all of the close minded straight men
that'll open up a dialogue how to deal
with being an older student around all
these goddamn kids Wow at a YouTube
channel I teach seventh and eighth grade
smelly bodies are a problem please play
my part and telling a kid they need
deodorant or a shower I've thought about
this okay here's my solution to your
problem day one of school hand out
deodorant to every kid in every class
buy some travel size you can get bulk on
Amazon I've done it hand them out to
every student you have and then just say
y'all smell it use this then you're not
outing one specific student and
hopefully
you know it works otherwise like I don't
know message someone Instagram how did
you know porn teachers ask them what
their actual passion was before they
settled on teaching
just kidding teachers make the world go
round how do I sneak food into class
without getting in trouble
wow this book is great no one will know
advice for teachers on how to survive
the first week take a [ __ ] in the middle
of the hallway and just look at everyone
and say quit me you'll set a tone do you
have any clever ways to hide my
open-heart surgery scar no because you
shouldn't cover that up girl you should
apply for open-heart surgery where that
scar loud and proud i drunkenly tripped
over a dog and fell down some stairs and
got stitches and have a scar above my
umbrella here and I wear it proudly how
am I going to pay back 150 K and loans
hand jobs
I mean jobs getting a job comes in handy
going back to college in a month how to
tell frat boys you're not interested a
Taser as a teacher how do I keep myself
from going insane because in the middle
of the hallway the first week of school
how do I not be an awkward human being
honestly I don't have an answer for this
what can I do to look like I give a [ __ ]
of class when I don't
I got you make glasses paper scissors
nah no one will know I'm going back to
school for the first time as a teacher
how do I prove to my middle school
students I'm cool take a show they tell
parents I dropped out of college
lmao send them this video
done and done I'm graduating in December
with my BA I'm also turning 40 in
November is that weird
no I'm 5 foot 4 but I'm going into my
final year how do I let the rest of
school know I deserve the same respect
given to my taller classmates a table
there you go there's some of my back
school advice hopefully this was helpful
make sure you guys subscribe to this
that's this is the wrong gesture for
subscribing like this video by clicking
the like button and subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometimes that bail
notification on so you get notified
because it's not consistent
I don't know how do you handle anxiety
when being overwhelmed by homework while
also having a social life just to remind
yourself that life gets like infinitely
harder after you graduate high school
and/or college you have a safety net
right now you're being a [ __ ] life gets
sucky so enjoy it while you can
subscribe